[Musique]
j'ai toujours cherché des solutions qui
peuvent être mises en place rapidement 8
pour diminuer l'exclusion sociale qui
existe dans la plupart des zones isolées
de notre planète
[Musique]
à pied ici nous essayons d'implanter un
modèle d'accès à l'énergie renouvelable
qui soit facile et rapide à mettre en
place notre modèle utilise des énergies
propres qui sont toujours plus facile à
obtenir
en l'occurrence nous utilisons l'énergie
solaire l'énergie photovoltaïque
[Musique]
mon premier projet c'était dans le sud
du pays
j'ai installé l'électricité dans une
municipalité de 6000 familles j'ai
commencé à 22 ans
aujourd'hui j'en ai 50 et pendant toutes
ces années j'ai cherché à implanter
l'énergie électrique en organiser la
bonne utilisation pour aider au
développement local
mon objectif c'est d'éradiquer la
pauvreté et la misère l'exclusion
sociale secrétaire municipal chargé des
questions de développement agricole en
1992 fabio rossa abandonne la politique
et créer ideas une entreprise qui
s'investit dans la recherche d'énergies
nouvelles au service des plus pauvres
le premier objectif de l'équipe d'ideas
amener l'électricité dans les villages
les plus reculés et les plus isolés de
la forêt amazonienne
tout est beau ici vous habitez dans un
paradis comment ça va nous étudions les
conditions de vie de la population
locale
nous essayons de comprendre comment
optimiser le potentiel énergétique que
ces populations il on les utilise la
création de nos projets répondent tous à
une même méthode
premièrement nous allons sur le terrain
pour écouter les besoins des gens on
commence à développer des produits et
des solutions qui doivent résoudre leurs
problèmes ils combien de familles vivent
ici
soixante trois pour une population de
combien de personnes 321 une personne de
ses 63 familles combien possède
l'installation des panneaux solaires une
trentaine je crois
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle j'ai quitté mon
travail de banquier et de consultants
financiers pour me tourner vers
l'entrepreneuriat social
c'est pour donner un sens à ma vie c'est
remettre du plaisir dans ce que l'on
fait au quotidien
je ne veux plus courir uniquement après
les résultats financiers ce qui est la
principale source de motivation dans le
secteur privé à l'arrivée je veux qu'il
y ait un sens à ce que je fais vendeur
du manioc existe-t-il une autre source
de revenus la pêche mais très peu vous
avez d'autres activités économiques
qu'on pourrait développer ici dans la
région comme l'artisanat le tourisme
l'artisanat aussi bien sûr du quel type
d'artisanat le tressage de la baille
j'ai l'habitude de dire que nous avons
créé un marché
ce terme de marché qui est
habituellement liés au capitalisme moi
je l'entends comme le lieu où des
besoins se font connaître le marché
c'est une zone des changes entre ceux
qui ont des besoins et ceux qui
apportent des solutions
avec l'installation de panneaux solaires
relié à un système de batterie mis au
point par l'équipe d'ideas fabio a fait
passer de 7000 à 400 dollars le coût des
branchements d'un village
ça va bien commentcamarche électricité
et si ça marche bien
le problème c'est la télé puisqu'elle à
la télé ne marche pas elle veut passer à
lui mais on va les voir je vais mettre
un panneau de plus ici comme il a une
télé de 20 pouces ça consomme 80 watts
et il a besoin de plus d'énergie
alors il faut le système à deux panneaux
comme l'autre maison
[Musique]
mon
l'intérêt pour moi d'avoir l'électricité
oulala c'est énorme avoir de la lumière
ça a tout changé
avant on n'avait pas de sources
d'électricité on n'avait rien quand on
travaillait ici ça faisait mal aux yeux
on s'éclairait à la bougie ou à la lampe
à pétrole qui chauffe et sent tellement
mauvais maintenant qu'on a de
l'électricité tout va bien on a de l'eau
courante de la lumière et tout est plus
simple grâce à dieu
[Musique]
il ya nous implantons en ce moment un
centre d'apprentissage pour sensibiliser
les gens à la possibilité de produire et
de gérer eux mêmes leur propre énergie
sa
je voudrais savoir si vous connaissez
l'énergie solaire le lieu est ouvert à
tous sans qu'il puisse comprendre
comment marche l'efficience énergétique
et la conservation énergétique dans leur
propre maison
nous voulons qu'ils puissent l'intégrer
dans leur quotidien derrière les
panneaux solaires il existe des
personnes et des besoins humains que
l'on doit accorder avec l'environnement
surpris qu'on respecte hormis un bien
cat social le marché spécial est un
marché qu'une bonne partie des gens
n'arrivent pas à comprendre parce qu'il
n'est pas conventionnel il se manifeste
d'une autre façon c'est en quelque sorte
un marché souterrain
aujourd'hui avec le soutien du président
lula ideas est mandaté pour étudier des
projets d'installations électriques pour
les camps de réfugiés en afrique et pour
la reconstruction d'haïti
le plus grand défi est la plus grande
difficulté c'est de convaincre des
partenaires des investisseurs de
l'existence de ce marché aujourd'hui le
capitalisme doit faire des compromis
avec les questions humaines et éthiques
elles doivent passer avant les intérêts
commerciaux et la rentabilité
ce sont ces compromis qui vont donner du
sens aux futures grandes découvertes
liées à l'activité humaine
[Musique]